[Música]
bienvenidos a cinco minutos con nueve
diez años después de las revueltas
populares pacíficas en siria que
derivaron en una sangrienta guerra civil
el drama del conflicto o traspasó las
fronteras con los refugiados el mayor
éxodo desde la segunda guerra mundial es
dejas cifras alarmantes más de 5.7
millones de sirios han huido del país en
busca de un futuro digno y para hablar
de este tema nos acompaña esteban
beltrán director de amnistía
internacional en españa gracias el señor
beltrán por acompañarnos y quiero
comenzar preguntándole mientras países
vecinos como líbano turquía o jordania
acogen a la mayoría de refugiados
procedentes de cydia más de 4 millones
la crisis migratoria desatada en 2015 en
el mediterráneo' dejó patente la falta
de cooperación y de solidaridad de los
países europeos como es la situación
actual de los refugiados que residen en
el viejo continente
bueno la situación de los refugiados
solo de mencionar que es solamente
alemania estuvo a la altura de las
circunstancias acogiendo que hace un
millón de personas restantes europeos y
tiene de poco país pues simplemente no
acoger a las personas puso todos los
problemas que darían para que la gente
no podía llegar colaboro se ha cumplido
ahora el aniversario de la colaboración
con turquía para bloquear la llegada de
refugiados a europa por lo tanto él a
pesar de se hunde ese éxodo inéditos de
la segunda guerra mundial pues la
protección a los refugiados sirios que
huían de la represión y que siguió
huyendo porque en 2019 hubo otra oleada
de refugiados consigue sino muy difícil
tanto la acogida como la falta de vías
legales y seguras para que lleguen a
europa de soluciones
y además está el tema de que en síria
millones de personas simplemente no
cuentan con los recursos para pagar a
las mafias y poder salir del país más
del 50% de la población está en
situación de desplazamiento interno pero
la violencia y la represión por parte
del gobierno de bachar al asad y por
parte de los otros actores del conflicto
como los yihadistas y los rebeldes
continuó en muchas partes del territorio
junto con la crisis humanitaria cuáles
son las amenazas que enfrentan los
desplazados sirios al interior del país
bueno la situación en siria lejos de
haber determinado lamentablemente a
continuación es desoladora no hay una
ola de hostilidades que amenaza a la
población civil del nordeste del país
que incluye y dilip alepo hama en dará
el suelo del sur por ejemplo continúe es
la inseguridad y la represión continuada
detenciones desapariciones forzadas
comicios legítimos quizá lo que es más
grave el gobierno sirio por ejemplo
sigue restringiendo la guía de ayuda
humanitaria a las zonas bajo su control
y todavía el gobierno sirio se apoya
especialmente en rusia y en ahí
y en china pero sobre todo en rusia para
seguir una política de tierra quemada y
con la para lo que los que en relación a
los 15 millones de personas que están
bajo su control y sobre todo en la parte
también del sur de este país realmente
muy poca esperanza la esperanza para
romper este círculo debería venir de
romper el círculo de impunidad y de que
se siga lo que ya se intentó en alemania
los alemanes que es juzgar a una persona
por torturas sistemáticas en damasco y
esa esa ruptura de los círculos de
impunidad podría ser la esperanza de que
yo pudiera mejorar huanchilla y para el
cierre le quiero preguntar algunos
hablan ya de posguerra en siria pero el
país está devastado y eso es muy
discutible podrán volver los sirios en
el exilio a su nación qué condiciones se
tienen que dar para que esto ocurra
no existe las condiciones actualmente
para regresarlo lo que le llevó al
levantamiento de la gente en marzo del
2011 quienes la pobreza la corrupción la
represión la manera la mala gestión y la
injusticia hablas tanto la impunidad son
ahora mucho peores diez años después por
lo tanto en estos momentos no hay las
condiciones para regresar en
conducciones para la redundancia de
seguridad a siria yo creo que todavía lo
que queda pendiente es que los
refugiados estén en mejores códigos
donde están pero que nadie regrese si no
lo quiere hacer voluntariamente a siria
no se dan las condiciones para que la
gente regrese y cuáles en condiciones de
seguridad y para tener una vida digna
pues muchísimas gracias a ustedes ni
siquiera empezamos a hablar de las
secuelas que traen estos desplazamientos
forzosos en las vidas de millones de
ciudadanos sirios hasta aquí cinco
minutos con ustedes continúe con toda
nuestra programación de france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]